c'est un projet qui existe depuis
longtemps et le gens se demandent si
enfin il va se réaliser et or ça fait à
peu près un an qu'on travaille dessus et
que les choses se font et on me demande
si c'est ce qui va se faire et ce qu'il
va pas se faire donc c'est de rendre
compte de ce qu'on est en train de faire
et ce de ce qu'on va faire
effectivement l'autre chose c'est aussi
de vraiment expliquer ce que c'est qu'un
cyclotron parce que le cyclotron c'est
pas ça qui va soigner les patients
c'est une étape essentielle pour faire
un diagnostic qui est vraiment créé dans
les prises en charges cancéreuses mais
aussi dans les prises en charges
neurologiques ou autre et donc là c'est
vraiment pour démystifier et expliquer
ce qu'on est en train de faire et à quoi
ça va servir
il ya un examen clé qui est essentielle
pour savoir quelle est la teinte du
cancer au sein de la personne qu'on
n'est pas capable de faire
donc cet examen il peut se faire soit en
métropole soit en guadeloupe pour
certains types d'examens mais à chaque
fois ça demande du temps or souvent on a
besoin de ce bilan d'extension de
manière très rapide donc ça on va le
faire sans l'examen en se disant base il
y en a peut-être pas besoin donc on va
opérer la personne alors que peut-être
un peu besoin ou là on prend les gens de
manière moins optimale ou alors on prend
le temps de faire un examen et ça c'est
un petit peu plus alors le financement
de ce projet c'est un projet global de
entre 25 et 30 millions d'euros et à 11
millions
d'euros qui sont amenés par la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
il ya à peu près 5 millions d'euros qui
seront amenés par spécifiquement par la
rs et puis après ça il ya la rs et
l'état qui participent à nos
investissements en grande partie une
partie qui qu'on va trouver en propre